2015 is coming in hot last month was the
hottest may on record it's also been the
warmest start to a year since agencies
have been keeping records and that
started in the 1880s so who are the
players looking to help combat or
capitalize on or both at the same time
hopefully the effects of global warming
into summer long series we're calling
changing climate changing business I
want to welcome Proterra CEO Ryan pople
Proterra
is among the leading providers of zero
emission battery electric buses just
announced a new 55 million dollar round
of funding so I guess congratulations on
that and what are you going to do with
the money Ryan well thank you very much
for the congratulations that the first
thing we're going to do with the capital
is we're going to grow we had already
reached the point where we had a
one-year backlog on our first Factory
and we wanted to make sure that we could
keep up with the growing demand for zero
emission transit vehicles in this market
so we're going to open a second factory
it'll be in Southern California and
it'll give us the ability to serve both
markets in the United States East Coast
and West Coast very efficiently do
different cities have different needs
you know that's the great thing about
this market is that for the most part a
bus is a bus and that's that's the same
nationally as it is internationally
every city across the planet has the
same set of problems you've got growing
population you've got growing traffic
congestion and you have real concerns
even in countries where we would
consider that we have pretty advanced
regulations on air quality towards
things like smog and pollution you know
I'm going to assume that they're more
expensive than a traditional bus but
that you save money on obviously fuel
maintenance etc so how does it net out
as far as cost sure so at the moment
it's more expensive than combustion but
we see a path where Evy becomes cheaper
on a first cost basis to hybrid to CNG
and then to the conventional diesel bus
the technology needed to build an EB
transit bus is quite simple and the cost
of the batteries is coming down
dramatically
so today the simplest case to think
about would be that a diesel bus is
about $400,000 for a city but they're
going to spend another million dollars
on fuel and maintenance over 12 years
you compare that to an Eevee bus and for
12 year deployment you can buy the
vehicle the electricity and the
maintenance for a million dollars so
save 400,000 while raising money is
clearly a successful sign there's
investors who believe in you where do
you stand on making money so fourth
quarter of last year we are cashflow
positive we are just about breakeven in
February and we're cashflow positive in
April so if we wanted to we could turn
off R&D now and become a profitable
company in the short order but that's
not what our investors want us to do
they see the potential for this
technology to completely replace
combustion and when you look out there
and see 70,000 diesel buses in cities in
the US alone they're really pushing us
to advance the technology further and
faster we've really set the bar for what
this technology can do but over the next
five years you're going to see these
vehicles be able to out-compete compete
combustion on every metric all right hey
Ryan thanks very much Proterra CEO Ryan
Popple there with big electric buses
zero emission buses